aller tout de suite en Pologne où on
nous annonce une rencontre entre André
Juda et Joe Biden à Varsovie première
réunion de travail première rencontre
entre le président polonais et le
président américain on va écouter
du
[Musique]
flan symbolique une visite exclusivement
date notre région mais et
avec la visite inquiète c'est une c'est
un signal global permanent que vous
envoyez un monde entier et vous prenez
sur vos épaules là sécurité
de l'Europe à maintes reprises les
États-Unis ont démontré le
responsabilité leur a engagement pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale pendant la
guerre froide et à chaque fois vous avez
un vrai pour les retours en principe
démocratique pour que les gens
deviennent redeviennent libres pour
qu'il puisse revenir à une vie normale
comme c'était le cas en Pologne en bout
de décennies comme en
1918 en Pologne et grâce justement aussi
à l'influence du très sincère que nous
adorons Jean-Paul II
nous savons que aussi c'est votre
politique
intransigeante qui a été
conduite par le président Regan pour
combattre justement l'empire du mal et
nous avons retrouvé
notre liberté et en regardant tout ce
que vous avez accompli hier et nous
pouvons constater que les États-Unis
sont capables de maintenir un ordre
mondial de faire
front à l'agresseur qui voudrait rendre
esclave de notre nation nous ne serons
jamais d'accord c'est-à-dire la
communauté démocratique que représente
justement les États-Unis
d'admettre de tels comportements et
comme j'ai déjà dit pour nous les
Polonais c'est un signe extrêmement
important de notre point de vue de la
sécurité de la Pologne nous sommes
heureux de votre visite et nous sommes
sûrs que vous allez envoyer un message
fort vers le monde entier parce que je
pense que les yeux du monde entier sont
tournés justement vers cette visite en
Pologne
et nous ne pouvons que nous réjouir
et puis de mettre l'accent et des
contrats de voir de constater et quelle
importance les États-Unis attachent à la
sécurité à nos actions en Pologne ça
nous convaincre dans le bon choix que
nous effectuons quand tu viennes en nous
nous soutenons en permanence l'Ukraine
nous les soutenons de multiples façons
dans la mesure du possible et nous
sommes convaincus que notre choix notre
chemin est juste
le soutien que vous nous obtenons de la
part des États-Unis nous le en quelque
sorte partageant avec nos alliés
[Musique]
la Pologne se sent en sécurité vous
pouvez séjourner dans notre feuille à
l'autre bout de la de la planète même si
les distances maintenant ne sont pas
aussi importantes la Pologne est un pays
sûr grâce aussi à la présence de nos
alliés sur le territoire de la Pologne
et des soldats américains et nous
faisons tous nos possibles tout nos
efforts évidemment pour renforcer la
sécurité et nous mettons en oeuvre
toutes nos potentiels justement et je
pense que vous
représentez de façon très visible
justement tous ces engagements et
pendant les rencontres que j'ai eu avec
mes homologues aussi bien à Munich
pendant la conférence de sécurité ou à
Londres à chaque fois
je souligne justement
que notre lien
translatlantique l'All Atlantique est
extrêmement
fort notre premier ministre monsieur
moravitki il est justement à la gouverne
en quelque sorte et il
veille justement sur le actions du
Parlement de décision de Parlement
polonais bientôt nous aurons la
présidence polonaise à l'Union
européenne et nous voulons aussi
célébrer l'anniversaire de la présence
polonaise de l'intégration polonaise à
l'Union européenne c'est-à-dire
renforcer nos liens avec l'OTAN encore
plus de présence des États-Unis en Union
Européenne renforcer notre collaboration
et aussi bien dans sur le plan
économique sur le plan de la sécurité
sécuritaire
exactement maintenant nous avons
beaucoup de tâches extrêmement
compliquées à remplir et je pense que
vous faites justement
démonstration de de cette clé de la
sécurité futur pour pour laquelle nous
devrons en Europe c'est-à-dire surtout
de nous regardons notre histoire
polonaise dans la perspective de du
siècle dernier bienvenue en Pologne
donc je suis désolé de revenir encore
une fois et de bénéficier encore une
fois de votre accueil très généreux donc
je vous aide je suis très reconnaissante
de votre nouvelle invitation vous avez
mes idées le pape Jean-Paul et je dois
dire que j'ai une vieille histoire à
raconter j'avais véritablement
quelqu'un de toute façon enfin important
dans le personnel qui était dans notre
comité qui était la deuxième plus jeune
personne est avait 23 33 ans et je suis
rentré d'Europe en disant et bien j'ai
dit que la Pologne serait libérée en
quelques années et mon
directeur m'a dit il faut pas dire ça
parce que
tu vas avoir des ennuis et
Jean-Paul de m'appeler pour demander si
je voulais te parler avec lui et il est
encore plus conservateur que moi et je
voulais le voir et il a démarré la
conversation
il n'a jamais parlé de rien d'autre que
de la Pologne il s'était que la Pologne
et on est parti
d'un bout à l'autre de la Grande
Bibliothèque Caen et il y avait un
bureau
un bout et pas beaucoup d'espace et il
m'a dit vous voulez une photo j'ai dit
votre santé j'adore et j'aimerais
beaucoup et on est allé du bureau
jusqu'à l'autre bout et il y avait le
feu dans il m'a dit sénateur
rappelez-vous que je vous ai apporté en
tant que Paul et pas en tant que Pape et
j'ai me rend compte de l'importance et
du pouvoir qu'il avait véritablement
donc c'est une histoire à laquelle je
tiens beaucoup et qui était
véritablement
très importante et c'est important
d'être côte à côte de montrer notre
détermination et
les Nations Unies et les États-Unis ont
besoin de Paul et les autres également
et je ne sais pas où pour qui pourrait
aller au-delà de ce que nous avons nous
avons besoin de cette sécurité en Europe
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
essentiel c'est ce qui a le plus
d'importance et de
provoquer les conséquences dans la vie
dans l'histoire moderne la sécurité en
Europe joue quelque chose de tout à fait
essentiel et je me souviens du
Commentaire des
engagements des États-Unis de leurs
alliés et en disant que je voudrais
avoir quelque chose de toujours plus
fort et lorsque nous avons discuté
précédemment j'ai dit avec fierté que
notre soutien à l'Ukraine dépend
véritablement de nous tous et j'ai dit à
quel point il était important en
chercher la finalisation de le temps et
maintenant on cherche le tennis
d'affectation de la Finlande mais
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait dire et
véritablement si nous voulons poursuivre
rester concentré et nous nous allons
progresser de façon importante Audrey
véritablement je vous soutiens
véritablement pour le soutien
pantalukraine c'est tout à fait
extraordinaire ce que vous avez fait
véritablement et lorsque je regardais
les gens traversaient la frontière
l'année dernière et je voyais ces femmes
et les enfants et que je voyais le
visage de ces mères et que je pensais
que leur mari leur père était si active
ils étaient véritablement si nombreux il
y avait des un million un million et
demi d'ukrainien qui passait cette
frontière et nous avons réaffirmé et
je me souviens ce qu'il les mettre en
sécurité et véritablement que le chef
d'état-major de nos forces en Europe à
l'être en Pologne c'est tout c'était la
décision à prendre et puis de voir ce
partenariat stratégique qui devait se
développer et qui devait renforcer la
situation Pologne et qui devait assurer
la sécurité des générations à venir donc
monsieur le Président je voudrais
véritablement
dire que les biens entre le peuple
américain et le peuple polonaise
extrêmement fort et en tant que jeune
homme j'étais nommé
j'étais au nord de la peine visanie et
j'avais un voisin
qui est nous emmener à twinko et qui est
une ville pas très loin et tout le monde
en ville disait les Polonais sont des
Italiens et
mon nom avait escaillé à la fin et donc
on voit la force de l'ukrain de ce lien
et la fierté qui m'amenait j'avais
rajouté ce qui à la fin donc les
Polonais d'Amérique ont un sentiment
très fort vis-à-vis de la Pologne et
c'est véritablement quelque chose qui
est très important et si vous si vous
venez
c'est quelque chose que vous voyez vous
voyez les défis que nous avons à relever
il faut les relever ensemble et
développer notre partenariat nous avons
besoin de relever tous ces défis et je
suis véritablement très heureuse je suis
heureux d'être de retour chez vous de
voir que nous pouvons avoir encore des
discussions et puis le président vont
aller dans une autre salle des problèmes
vont symboler véritablement la situation
nous avons une région une relation qui
est tout à fait
l'ancienne essentiel essentiel pour les
États-Unis et je vous en remercie